[Music]
in the 1960s
the scope of nlm was radically expanded
by both the congress and the secretary
in terms of creating our first
intramural research division the lister
hill
national center for biomedical
communication transferring
the public health service audio visual
facility
to the national library of medicine from
the cdc just radically expanded what the
library
[Music]
did
the satellite group was having trouble
finding anybody that wanted to use
satellites
so we caught got about three
medical libraries in the northwest part
of the country
and set up a direct communication
between alaska and the library of
medicine
and we transmitted excellent data that
needed
and relied on medical images
[Music]
high-speed computer networks are under
development and the foundations for that
network
are already in place in a really global
network called the internet we'll take a
little adventure with your
united states senator here and see what
he can do by introducing the internet
grateful med the super highway
on medical information will now become
a freeway this development by itself
may do more to reform
and improve the quality of healthcare in
the united states
than anything else we've done in a long
time i mean we actually at nlm alone
answer a million inquiries a day
a day a day it's a staggering amount
it's going 400 million a year
it was evident to us if we could get
involved in this type of a project we
could bring our
access out to people in rural iowa
nlm has really provided the seed money
for a project that's no longer a
research project
it's practice now for us
this is a tremendous accomplishment in
fact snowmed
is going to be distributed by the
national library of medicine through its
unified medical language system
[Music]
i get a call from don lindberg asking me
to be
a regent and i said i i don't get it you
know it's it's a library he says well
libraries are just collections of data
aren't they we see imaging is just as
important as
as books i'm that's that's that's
enlightened yeah
we have a personal health record that's
now demonstrable
this is based on web technology as
teacher rich as a desktop application
would be
the key data input is coded into nlm
supported vocabularies oftentimes the
national library of medicine
that i turn to and not just as a
reporter but also as a doctor
clinicaltrials.gov is a place that i
often send my patients
the national importance of that resource
for patients and families and really
for the world continues to make a
difference i think
people had associated the national
library of medicine perhaps with the
adjective venerable
but a little staid and conservative and
we took it right to the other end of the
slider bar
in terms of adventuresomeness and doing
things that we didn't quite actually
know how to do with unified medical
language system and
creating ncbi new avenues in digital
imaging and new services in an internet
world though
that was a very heady time
[Music]
[Applause]
you